president trump gets acquitted by the
senate despite seven republicans voting
in favor of conviction
the biden administration is openly
screwing with the science hankovic just
to please the teachers unions
and president biden's radical
administration it's just getting started
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn for peace of mind whenever
you go online visit expressvpn.com
ben we'll get to all the news in just
one moment quickly a reminder just want
to tell you you could be saving a lot of
money on that cell phone bill
i know you haven't thought about in a
while but the reality is every time you
ignore
your bill monthly you're just letting
the money it goes straight down the
toilet or
to those cell phone providers and again
you don't need to do that instead you
should be checking out puretalk usa
over a thousand of you my extremely wise
listeners have made the switch
from your overpriced wireless carrier to
peer talk over the past couple of months
what exactly are the rest of you waiting
for if you're with att verizon or
t-mobile your family could save over 800
a year just by switching to pure talk
yet the same great coverage because they
use the exact same towers
as one of the big carriers you can even
keep your phone and your number but you
will save a fortune by the way puretalk
is the top rated wireless company
by consumer affairs with the absolute
best customer service team based right
here in america
sound good it gets better right now get
a limited talk text and six gigs of data
for just 30 bucks a month
and if you go over on data they're not
going to charge you for it grab your
mobile phone nut pound 250 say my name
ben shapiro to get started when you do
you save 50
off your first month so i'll pound it
two five zero say keyword ben shapiro
pure talk usa is simply smarter wireless
go check them out
right now by dialing pound two five zero
and say
my name ben shapiro to get 50 off your
very first month okay so
over the weekend on saturday president
trump became the first president
ever to go for two two for two in
impeachment acquittal so he's been
impeached twice
it happened basically within the space
of a year and he was
acquitted twice by the senate this time
there were more votes to impeach him or
convict him in the senate than there
were last time around last time it was a
straight party vote with only mitt
romney breaking ranks this time there
were seven republicans
breaking ranks according to abc news
exactly a month and a week
after insurrectionists incited a riot at
the capitol on january 6th
and you got to love the the loaded
language there from abc news former
president donald trump's second
impeachment trial came to a climactic
end on saturday afternoon with trump
being acquitted for his alleged role in
inciting the deadly event a majority of
senators voted to convict but failed to
reach the super-majority threshold
needed for conviction
trump said in a statement this has been
yet another phase of the greatest witch
hunt in the history of our country
no president has ever gone through
anything like it it continues because
our opponents cannot forget the almost
75 million people the highest number
ever for a sitting president who voted
for us just a few
short months ago he's not totally wrong
about this particular fact the reality
is that since he was elected in 2016
there were many many people who simply
could not accept the fact that trump
was president and then there were a lot
of people who were so upset that 75
million americans voted for him
in november that they attempted to
essentially lump in
all of those people with the capital
rioters i've been saying this since the
day it happened it was pretty obvious
that the left-wing and media agenda here
was to lump everybody in together with
the people who committed actual criminal
and evil act
on january 6th president trump said our
historic patriotic beautiful movement to
make america great again has only just
begun
in the months ahead i have much to share
with you i look forward to continuing
our incredible journey together to
achieve american greatness for all of
our people there has never been
anything like it drama ensued on the
senate floor on saturday morning when
senators voted to hear from witnesses so
here is the reality here
the reality is that democrats made it
kind of easy on republicans
i should be frank about this democrats
blew this one the reason that they blew
this one
is because they recognized a simple
reality the longer this trial
dragged out the more americans were
going to ask a very easy question
why are we doing this like really this
is what always happens with impeachment
at the very beginning there's a fair bit
of support for them and then as they
drag on the polls start to turn against
the party that's doing the impeachment
that is particularly true when the
person they are attempting to impeach
and convict
has been out of office for months
because democrats did not want to call
witnesses they wanted to get this thing
done fast so democrats made two mistakes
here like
very early they made some mistakes one
was they had a snap impeachment in the
house
now the argument for the snap
impeachment in the house was that this
happened on january 6th well impeachment
by january 10th we'll get him out of
there by january 15th
and then we won't have to worry about
the last five days him leading some sort
of insurrection
but here's the thing democrats didn't
believe that because if democrats
had actually believed that then they
would have moved fast in the senate
which they did not
remember nancy pelosi passed the
impeachment in the house with
essentially a straight party line vote
10 republicans voting in favor
and then instead of transmitting the
articles of impeachment to the senate
right away
she waited for like a very long weekend
in order to get it to the senate
and by that point it was basically five
days from the time that trump was to
leave office anyway so that wasn't
enough time for the senate to actually
do its work
so if the idea is we need to get rid of
this guy like asap right now because
he's so dangerous
then she would have transmitted it right
away which was the explanation for of
course why they had a snap impeachment
in the first place
if however the idea here is that you
have to punish a president who's no
longer in
office because we can't let a future
president think he can get away with
this sort of stuff well then he wouldn't
have had the snap impeachment would you
you have had a full-scale investigation
the house would have done its work
it would have taken months they would
have deposed probably hundreds of
witnesses
they would have had to talk to everybody
immediately around trump about his
activities
that day and immediately before and
after they didn't do any of that
so what that meant is that you ended up
with the democrats basically catching
his catch can which suggests that again
their strategy here
was not really to get a conviction their
strategy here was almost entirely about
painting one side of the political aisle
as complicit in january 6th
that's really what this was about
because again if it was about snap
impeachment they would have moved faster
in the first place
and then once they got past trump
leaving office
the rationale for the snap impeachment
was gone because he was out
right now would be the time for the
full-scale investigation
so what could have happened while the
senate could have called witnesses and
this is what it came down to over the
weekend there was this really really
bizarre situation in which democrats
reverse themselves
on witnesses so what happened is that
there was a republican congressperson
who basically was going to testify that
she had talked to kevin mccarthy
and kevin mccarthy had talked to trump
and kevin mccarthy had told trump to
call off
the dogs and trump didn't call off the
dogs or any of this and so
this came out late on on friday night
early saturday morning
and the democrats in the house then
voted you know what maybe we should call
witnesses
and then the senate democrats voted
maybe we should call witnesses and then
within an
hour they reversed themselves on
saturday morning say you know what
forget it we're not going to call
witnesses let's just let's just take a
vote
according to the washington post the
debate among the house impeachment
managers raged through the night
as the hours and then minutes ticked
down early saturday before it was widely
expected to be the final day of former
president donald trump's senate trial
after weeks of bending to political
pressure to ensure a speeding proceeding
some on the house team wanted to make
one final furious push to demand a more
intensive investigation
to call witnesses to talk about trump's
behavior before during and after the mob
attack on the capitol on january 6th
right which again that that is a
position that makes sense if you believe
that this was such a grave evil and
injustice on the part of trump right now
not on the part of the writers on the
part of trump
that you required a full-scale 911 style
commission well then you should have
done that
and so how some of the house impeachment
managers were like okay well you know
what
i know we're supposed to vote on this
thing but why don't we go ahead and do
that and senate democrats initially were
like well
okay and then they reverse themselves
according to the washington post should
they seek to call a republican lawmaker
who was willing to talk about her
knowledge
of trump's dismissive comments to the
house gop leader who pled with him
during a riot to call off his supporters
should they call the leader himself
kevin mccarthy what about aids to former
vice president mike pence whose dramatic
of actual
evacuation was caught on security video
played for the first time publicly last
week
any of these moves risked extending the
proceedings for weeks but nonetheless
these potential surprise developments
consumed the managers late into friday
night and in the wee hours on saturday
according to multiple democrats with the
deliberate who are familiar with the
liberations
in the end the managers backed off
allowing the senate vote to take place
as expected but not
before a chaotic back and forth caught
senators off guard sent trump's legal
team into a fury and exposed
long-simmering tensions among democrats
over how aggressively to hold the former
president
accountable the debate over witness
testimony continued to learn large after
the vote
as key questions about trump's actions
and motives remained unanswered see this
was the big problem there were two big
problems with the democrats impeachment
push one was
the actual impeachment charge which
centered around incitement
incitement is very difficult to prove
suggesting that trump quote unquote
incited the riot when he said to
peacefully
and patriotically march down to the
capital to show displeasure
that is not a particularly convincing
argument because again incitement is a
pretty high bar
and suggesting that it was incitement to
insurrection is a double high bar
because again you have to show number
one that it was incitement
and number two that trump actually
wanted an insurrection not just people
to go and do something criminal he
wanted an insurrection to overthrow the
united states government
which again there's very little evidence
of so that was problem
number one with all of this the second
problem over all of this
is that many of the accusations that
were being made about trump's behavior
were being made
second or third hand it was unnamed
staffer inside the white house talking
to new york times and the democrats
didn't bother to call witnesses
they just cited the new york times
report that ain't going to be good
enough
to support an impeachment effort and
we're going to get to more of this
in just one second first let's talk
about the fact that
the second amendment it's going to be
under fire now okay joe biden we'll get
to this a little bit later on the show
joe biden is now proposing widespread
gun bans he's talking about an assault a
so-called assault weapons ban he's
talking about limitations on magazines
and all the rest of it
this means now would be an excellent
time to protect your own individual
liberty and your second amendment right
to keep and bear arms by heading on over
to our friends over bravo company
manufacturing
they know that owning a rifle is an
awesome responsibility and that building
rifles is no different which is why i am
so impressed
with bcm the people over at bravo
company manufacturing support the right
of responsible private individuals to
have the access and ability to employ
the same tools as civilian law
enforcement
as a means of defending ourselves our
loved ones our communities and our
freedoms
should god forbid a threatening
situation ever arise bcm assumes that
when a rifle leaves their shop it will
be used in a life or death situation
by a responsible citizen law enforcement
officer or a soldier overseas
so quality is of the utmost value to
them every component of a bcm rifle is
hand assembled and tested by americans
as an american you have the luxury of
living in a free society where you can
improve your life through education and
religious exploration and open exchange
of ideas
all that stuff is protected by the
second amendment to learn more about
bravo company manufacturing
head on over to bravo company mfg
you can discover more about their
products special offers upcoming news
that's bravocompanymfg.com i have a
rifle from bravo company it is a
fantastic piece of machinery
if you need more convincing find out
even more about bcm and the awesome
people who make their products at
youtube.com
bravo company usa okay so
the the democrats put themselves in a
very difficult position with this
impeachment because they were very
inconsistent in their pursuits
first they said it was a crisis then
they said it was not a crisis
first they said that it was about
incitement for insurrection and then
they said it was about
trump's general activity between
november and january 6th
well they didn't try to bring an
impeachment charge against him in
december and he was saying exactly the
same things in january as he was saying
in december
for example and as it turns out a lot of
the language that they say that trump
was using that was quote unquote
incitement is language that has been
used by democrats over and over
this is the point that trump's team made
on friday when they were closing their
argument they just played tape over and
over of democrats
saying exactly the same kind of stuff
that trump has said and nobody batting
an eye
in the senate democrats are going to
fight like hell to make this a reality
we are going to fight like hell to
protect your vote well i'll tell you i'm
confident that we're going to fight like
hell to make sure they can
we are going to fight like hell to make
sure that everyone who wants to vote can
exercise that right to vote
this election is coming whether the
president wants it or not and we're
going to fight like hell in congress
to make sure that the mail still works
today biden's vp kamala harris
told supporters in a fundraising note
that it is time to quote
fight like hell to protect the supreme
court
okay so the the fact that the trump
impeachment managers the the defense
team
that they were saying you know you guys
use this kind of language all the time
and you have no problem with
it that is accurate i've said all along
there is no neutral standard the
democrats are going to uphold here
in going after trump on the basis of
incitement if they'd gone for a vaguer
charge i said this early on if they just
want to say abusive power
then it would have given republicans
some wiggle room but at the same time it
would have given them less wiggle room
on the one hand more wiggle room because
abusive power is not an actual legal
charge
on the other hand abuse of power is
probably a more
accurate description of what they think
trump did between november
and 4th and january 6th in any case here
was trump's lawyer saying you guys keep
saying incitement over and over and over
i'm not sure that that word means what
you think it means
at no point in their presentation did
you hear
the house managers play a single example
of mr trump urging anyone to engage
in violence of any kind at no point
did you hear anything that could ever
possibly be construed as mr trump
encouraging or sanctioning an
insurrection
senators you did not hear those tapes
because they do not exist
because the act of incitement never
happened
okay meanwhile the democrats are still
trying to make an excuse for why exactly
they didn't call the witnesses because
again if they wanted to show not only
incitement
but that there was action by trump on
january 6th to for example
hold up the sending of law enforcement
well then
now would have been the time jamie
raskin was trying to make excuses for
this he's like well you know
but you know what no matter what we said
no matter what we said
republicans would have just voted to
acquit number one that may very well be
true but that's not the point
the point is that if you wanted to
actually bring the strongest possible
impeachment charge
what you actually would have done is you
know the basic research here's jamie
raskin trying to make an excuse
for what was very obviously a
politically moded impeachment
trump knew exactly what they were doing
he knew that that mob which he had
deployed
was there you know occupying people's
offices and threatening
congress so it was there for everybody
to see right so we could have had a
thousand witnesses but that could not
have overcome
the kinds of silly arguments that uh
people like mcconnell and capital were
hanging their hats on
they're trying to have it both ways okay
but here's the problem you still have to
provide the evidence if you don't
provide the evidence you actually leave
republicans with the
perfectly plausible defense you guys
didn't provide the evidence of the chief
charge that you were attempting to make
but again this was all political from
the get-go there were seven republicans
who joined with the democrats to vote in
favor
of the conviction that had been senators
mitt romney of utah
not a surprise susan collins of maine
lisa murkowski of alaska ben sasse of
nebraska bill cassidy of louisiana
richard burr of north carolina and
patumi of pennsylvania
the latter two kind of interesting i
believe both of those guys are retiring
after this particular round because they
don't want to be primary presumably
there's already some talk of doing that
in these particular home states
but it does show that if you're in a
purple state they are less trumpy in the
purple states than they would be in the
non-purple states and that's something
that republicans should keep
in mind going forward which leads to
mitch mcconnell's response to all of
this
so mitch mcconnell did two things one he
voted against the impeachment because he
said listen you can't impeach somebody
who's already out of office
right otherwise you could just impeach
private individuals that's not what this
is really for
but he also slammed trump in pretty
personal terms it's pretty obvious that
mcconnell and many in the republican
higher echelon would like to separate
off from trump at this point you know
thanks for all the cheese but
we're done at this point here's mitch
mcconnell going after trump while
simultaneously not voting for his
impeachment
they did this because they'd been
fed wild falsehoods
by the most powerful man on earth
because he was angry he lost an election
former president trump's actions
preceded
the riot or a disgraceful
disgraceful their election
of duty okay so that is an argument
that's been made by a lot of republicans
is that trump's behavior
here was really really bad but what this
is really about from mcconnell and for a
lot of republicans is minimizing trump's
influence going forward
on the party and you can see why the
reality is that politically speaking
trump underperformed nearly every
republican across the country in 2020.
i know that that is counter to the sort
of prevailing view among republicans
which is that trump
boosted turnout on the right side of the
aisle he did boost some turnout on the
right side of the aisle but not for him
right he boosted turnout on the right
side of the aisle but he also boosted
turnout on the left side of the aisle
which is why joe biden
a dead candidate a person who has not
been living for several years ended up
winning 80 million votes in the popular
vote
so you can see why mcconnell is doing
what he's attempting to do here
which is i'm not going to separate off
from the party i understand that people
are using the impeachment
as a litmus test of loyalty to the
republican party i'm not going to
vote against that at the same time trump
should not be a key figure going forward
that's mcconnell's attempt meanwhile the
democrats are attempting
pretty strongly to tie all republicans
to trump's
knee here here's nancy pelosi suggesting
that every republican is complicit in
january 6
not just trump every single republican
who didn't vote in favor of impeachment
that was always the goal here right the
goal here was was never
that they were actually going to get a
conviction of trump or even that they
were going to do
the the leg work necessary to support an
impeachment of trump
instead it was really about how can we
best politically lump in everybody all
together really quickly and then move on
with our lives
pence hang mike pence was the chant
and they just dismissed that why because
maybe
they can't get another job what
is so important about any one of us
what is so important about the political
survival of
any one of us that is more important
than our constitution that we take an
oath to protect and defend
okay let me just say this about
political leaders when political leaders
grandstand this way you should never
believe them because political leaders
are are not meant to be moral leaders
they're just not as i was
we're getting to the portion of the
bible in in judaism every week we read a
different portion of the bible we're
getting the portion of the bible
at this point where the jews build the
golden calf it's right after they
receive the torah they receive the old
testament
and then moses goes back up the mountain
and they get they freak out and they
build the golden calf
and the question is why do they build a
golden calf what's so special about a
golden calf
and the reason that they build a golden
calf is because they want something that
is going to lead them but also be a
reflection of them
right something in which they had a part
right it says in the bible that all of
the israelites
all the jews they take out their nose
rings and their earrings and they melt
and they melt them down and they make
this god right then they're gonna
worship that god they worship the god
the neon god that they'd made right
this is what we do with our politicians
we elect these schmucks
i guess it's our fault and then we look
to them and we say why can't they lead
us
well they can't lead you because they're
reflections of you they're not gonna
tell you things you don't wanna hear
their literal job is to tell you things
that you want to hear this is what
politicians do for a living so when
nancy pelosi stands there and she says
things like
why do these politicians why do they
think that that their
own job is so much more important than
this institution yeah nancy
i'm sure that that consideration has
never crossed your mind under any
circumstances but but here's the reality
when it comes to pelosi and the
democrats and this impeachment
it was perfectly obvious what this was
from the beginning as soon as january
6th happened they saw it not as a
tragedy but as an opportunity for the
most part
it was both it was both for them it can
be both right it can be tragedy it can
be a criminal act
it can also be an opportunity
politically for them to ram down their
entire agenda
which is why they rushed this thing that
they've openly said this by the way
is that joe biden's agenda is more
important than taking their time with
the impeachment to determine whether
trump is actually guilty and convictable
what this was really about is making the
political point and then using that as
fuel
to push forward joe biden's ridiculous
agenda and his agenda is ridiculous
joe biden himself put out a statement he
says it was nearly two weeks ago that
jill and i paid our respects to capitol
police officer brian siknik who laid in
honor in the rotunda after losing his
life protecting the capital from a riot
as a violent mob
on january 6 2021. by the way we're
still finding out some of the details as
to what exactly happened with officer
nick the original reports that he was
hit in the head with a fire extinguisher
apparently are untrue that doesn't mean
he didn't die in defense of the capital
we just don't know
really much what happened at this point
biden said today
57 senators including a record seven
republicans voted to find former
president trump guilty of inciting that
deadly insurrection on our very
democracy
this senate vote followed the bipartisan
vote to impeach him by the house of
representatives
while the final vote did not lead to a
conviction the substance of the charge
is not in dispute
even those opposed to the conviction
like senate minority leader mcconnell
believed trump was guilty of a quote
unquote
disgraceful dear election of duty and
practically and morally responsible
for provoking the violence unleashed on
the capitol
okay well this would be the time
presumably for if that's true
right if that's what he believes that
it's not in dispute now it'd be a good
time to
recognize that everybody's on the same
side right but um that's not
what's going to happen here right so
biden says this is that
we have to realize that we all have a
duty and responsibility as americans to
defend the truth and defeat the lies
that's how we end this uncivil war
okay and the very first move the left
makes immediately is oh yeah and by the
way you need to
agree with all of the elements of our
agenda so charles blow over the new york
times symbolizing this point of view
he says blue lives matter is over weird
um i i noticed that you weren't a big
supporter of blue lives matter for like
this entire time
that in fact if you said blue lives
matter then charles blue got very very
upset with you because he was saying
that that is some sort of denigration of
the idea that black lives matter if you
suggest the police lives matter
but now he says blue lives matter is
over blue lives matter is over because
there were people who didn't vote in
favor
of convicting president trump in the
senate which means they don't care about
cops
now that argument could very well be
extended to black lives matter which
obviously does not give
two craps about the vast number of black
people who are being killed by other
black people in the united states this
is a point that has been
very well made by a bunch of advocates
for civil rights who happen to be on the
right side of the aisle which is that
black lives matter if it wanted to be
taken seriously
maybe they ought to worry about things
like the vast number of young black men
who are being killed by young black men
in cities that actually lack a police
presence
but charles blow would never say that
black lives matter doesn't care about
black lives
because of their absolute willingness to
to ignore
the risk to young black life in removing
the police but here he is saying blue
lives matter it doesn't matter to all
republicans because they didn't vote in
favor of conviction this is
all about the politics and democrats
never played it any other way
there was no point at which they said
that this was about a higher principle
or which they plausibly said that anyway
it was never about a higher principle
that was obvious from their conduct
it was obvious from how they laid out
the charge and it was perfectly obvious
from everything up to including the very
last day of this impeachment when they
could have called witnesses and decided
not to
out of political expedience one of the
democrats even admitting we just wanted
to get home for the weekend
yeah that sounds like principle to me
nancy pelosi alrighty in just a second
we're going to get to that radical biden
agenda because
i got to say they have now set out the
cdc
standards for covid in schools for
reopening the schools that are madness
we're gonna get to this in a second
because the party of science is just the
party of garbage we'll get to this in
one moment
one moment first let us talk about an
incredible organization i'm talking
about our friends over
at prager university the america we love
is slipping away you can feel it
are we going to let the left win victory
after cultural victory or
are we going to do something about it
prager university foundation it's better
known as prageru
they are a non-profit media powerhouse
several of us here
at the daily wire are featured in
prageru videos they're essentially one
of our sister
companies they're they're not affiliated
with us but we help them out
they're wonderful people over at prageru
prageru knows how to reach millions of
young people online
like no other non-profit young people
aren't hearing the reasons for america's
success they aren't learning our values
prageru
is addressing that head on if you want
to help save america the best way to do
it prageru.com forward slash
donate prageru's videos are watched 4
million times every single day
more than 70 percent of viewers say
their minds were changed after watching
and
more than 60 of these viewers are young
they are targeting the next
generation and they are doing so in
excellently produced fashion
they have videos from people like me
they have videos from people like
michael moles the videos from
all sorts of really interesting and
fascinating and important figures in the
conservative movement explaining
everything from the
merits of capitalism to the merits of
individual versus social justice
i have a video on intersectionality they
have all sorts of great stuff over at
prager you should go check them out
prageru is also leading the charge
against big tech censorship
fighting for our voices to be heard far
and wide prageru is on the front lines
of the cultural war every day they need
your help to supply the fight if you
want to be sure your donation dollars
will be used to support your values
donate to prageru today
at prageru.com forward slash daily wire
that is prageru.com
forward slash daily wire go check them
out right now they are well worthy
of your time and your money okay so
meanwhile
the the impeachment end and democrats
ended it early
because they really wanted to push
forward with this massive biden agenda
now here's the thing biden's cove agenda
is a bunch of garbage
it is garbage okay this 1.9 trillion
dollar stimulus plan
is about four times too large for even
the gap that is going to be created by
kova this year
it includes a bunch of terrible economic
policies like 15
minimum wage it is gonna blow a hole in
the national debt and deficit some of us
have been very
opposed to this even when donald trump
was president we already
are going to spend over 100 of our gdp
this year it's gonna be well above that
once we add that 1.9 trillion dollars in
inflation will come sooner or later
people going to realize we ain't paying
back this money without inflating the
currency
or without killing the american economy
through austerity measures
and so it is perfectly obvious where
this is all headed but
you want to know how politicized the
biden administration approach to things
is all you have to do is look
at their covet policy with regard to
schools because this is insane so let's
begin with this
they're liars over there they are they
the truth-telling team
in team biden they are liars here is
kamala harris the vice president of the
united states
suggesting again that there was no covet
vaccination strategy
when the biden team entered office this
is just overtly a lie
dr anthony fauci the greatest of all
doctors second only to joe biden he's
such an amazing doctor
dr fauci who's never switched his mind
on anything and has always been crystal
clear and has been perfectly consistent
and absolutely honest and forthright
with the american public i'm being super
sarcastic right here in case you can't
hear it in my voice but even dr fauci
said this is just a lie of course there
was a coveted vaccination strategy we
were giving a million shots a day
by the time that joe biden took office
you'll recall that joe biden then
declared he was going to give 100
million shots in the next hundred days
which averages out too i'm not amazing
at math but 100 divided by 100
is one so it's going to average out to 1
million shots a day amazingly we were
already giving a million shots a day by
the time biden took office but
apparently they inherited no plan
everybody knew this was a lie the media
know this is a lie but they never bother
following up on it even though it is
perfectly obviously a lie here is kamala
harris
presumably laughing over another lie
i mean the challenge mike is you know
what i explained
to the mayors um there was no stockpile
right it's in many ways
no stockpile of vaccines
right so we're looking at this there was
no national
strategy or plan for vaccinations
we were leaving it to the states and
local leaders to try and figure it out
and so in many ways we are com we're
starting from scratch
okay so that's just a lie they are not
starting from scratch they are not close
to starting from scratch
it's just untrue this is not to run down
biden's attempts to get new supply of
vaccine that's fine and every president
would have done it but i'm glad that
biden did it right that's a very good
thing i want more people to be
vaccinated because if you look at the
statistics from israel what you have
seen
is that now the death and illness from
kovid
is almost entirely in the under 60 crowd
because everybody over the age of 60s
got in the vaccine which is really good
but here is the thing
the the end policy for democrats right
now seems to be we are going to lock
down forever we're going to mask
forever until the end of time i'm not
kidding because the standards they are
currently setting
are not plausible under any
circumstances they're talking about
closing schools until the end of time
they're not
socially distancing until the end of
time so they brought out
these ridiculous cd stan center for
disease control standards over the
weekend now recall
that when donald trump was president
there was an article every single day
every day about how trump was putting
pressure on the cdc to change its
standards
and they admitted after trump's
presidency yeah the changes that we made
were pretty minor
these are not minor changes the cdc
standards on school reopenings are just
utterly asinine they make no sense
at all they are ridiculous on their face
so they put out a chart okay the chart
separated american counties into four
four separate categories ranked from red
on the upper end to blue on the lower
end sort of like the old terror chart
in the united states you remember this
one where i was like hi it was like the
the fire charts like
red zone of terror orange zone of terror
amazingly america has never been in the
blue zone of terror like the entire time
okay well the same thing is true of
covert so high transmission
was a certain number and then
substantial transmission and then
moderate transmission was yellow and
then low transmission was blue
okay so they say in all of these
circumstances
we have to implement five key mitigation
strategies one
universal and correct use of masks
required universal and correct use of
masks required
for presumably three and four-year-olds
not going to happen
you can't educate most adults on how to
use masks properly my four-year-old
son's pretty good at it like
he'll wear the mask but i gotta tell you
like i'm sure there are times where he
takes off his mask
physical distancing hand washing and
respiratory etiquette
yes i'm sure you're gonna teach a
five-year-old how not to cough cleaning
and maintaining healthy facilities
contact tracing in combination with
isolation and quarantine the cdc
standards by the way
recommend that if somebody in the class
has covet the entire class
be put out of class for 14 days even if
they have a negative test after five
which is totally anti-scientific it's
ridiculous
they say that symptomatic students
teachers and staff in close contact
should be referred for diagnostic
testing okay
then for low transmission in moderate
transmission counties they say that k-12
schools should be open for full
in-person instruction
physical distancing of six feet or more
to the greatest extent possible
and they say that sports and
extracurricular activities can occur but
there should be physical distancing of
six feet or more is the greatest extent
possible which is like okay i don't
understand how you're gonna play
basketball with six feet of distancing
but
sure okay then you get to the upper end
counties right substantial transmission
in orange and high transmission in red
for these the cdc now recommends
elementary schools should be in hybrid
learning mode
or reduced attendance physical
distancing of six feet or more is not
recommended
it should be required middle and high
schools in hybrid learning mode or
reduced attendance in the substantial
transmission or orange area
physical distancing of six feet or more
is required
no sports or extracurricular activities
unless they are held outdoors with
physical distancing and then in the high
transmission or red zones
then you can only attend in hybrid
learning mode or reduce attendance
middle and high schools in virtual only
instruction okay so no middles
no middle and high schools open at all
in the red zones
right and they or unless they can
strictly implement all mitigation
strategies and have few cases
schools that are already open can remain
open but only if they strictly implement
mitigation strategies and have a few
cases
and all sports and extracurricular
activities should be virtual only okay
now here's the thing
the research on this has shown schools
are not the chief vectors of
transmission particularly true for
elementary schools also true for younger
middle schoolers but even if you're
talking about high schoolers and junior
hires
those kids are not getting seriously ill
from this disease this disease is not
deadly on the scale of other diseases
with regard to people who are under the
age of 20. it is not
it is significantly less deadly for
people under the age of 20 than the flu
is
how about the risk for teachers it turns
out that the studies show there is no
additional risk to teachers against the
baseline of just being a normal human
adult moving around in american society
to being
to teaching in a school i'm as of yet
unaware
of a single teacher in america if you
can name me one i'm happy to hear it i
am not personally aware
of a teacher in america who has died as
a result of obtaining covet at a school
from a student
there are people who have obtained covet
and died i believe from other teachers
but not from the students as far as i'm
aware in the united states so the cdc
says that everybody in a red and an
orange zone should be back in hybrid
learning mode or not in school at all so
what does that mean i mean using these
zones okay but
maybe most of these places are in blue
most maybe most of america's in blue or
yellow and not in red or orange
um nope here is the map of the united
states
here is a map that shows two maps first
one shows
which schools are open and which schools
are not open
okay the ones that are that are uh the
the darkest purple here are the ones
that are essentially completely open
and then it kind of gradates down right
so 80 to 100 to open
would be like florida texas louisiana
right most of the upper midwest uh
places like north dakota south dakota
montana wyoming
right those places are going to be
almost all open and then there are a
bunch of states that are mostly open
right that remains most of the south
most of the midwest
uh arizona right those places are mostly
open
then there are places that are kind of
halfway open and that'd be like
that would be like uh michigan uh
wisconsin
right those states are kind of like
halfway open like 40 to 60 percent open
and then there are places that are
almost not open at all and that would be
essentially california
washington oregon going up the west
coast of the united states but bottom
line is this
at least half of american states are 60
or more open
okay and there are some states like
florida that are completely open by the
way florida's been completely open for
months
my kids have been in school the entire
year when there was a kid
who when there was a teacher who was
sick she went home when there was a
student who was sick in the middle
school
the class went home until a few days had
passed and then people took negative
tests and came back
if the schools had been open in florida
they never closed they didn't close in
florida
okay and here is what the map would look
like
if it were up to the cdc every red or
orange area
in the united states would be closed for
business with regard to schools they'd
go back to hybrid learning or virtual
learning only
if you're in a red or an orange zone if
you can't see this map it is safe to say
that literally 100 of all counties in
the united states
are yellow orange or red and probably 99
are red or orange okay so in other words
if it were up to the biden
administration and the cdc for the bible
administration they would re-shut
all the schools that are already open
that is what they would be doing
in fact jake tapper pointed this out
with cdc director wolensky he said um if
we're up to you guys
99 of all kids in all schools would be
barred from going to school
right now and uh and walensky was like
well yeah you know in the red zone
um we should even have hybrid elementary
schools welensky said
two weeks ago that schools should be
open and teachers don't need to be
vaccinated
now she has flipped on a dime and she
says in the red zones everything should
be shut and nearly all of america is red
zone here's rachelle lansky from the cdc
with jake tapper on cnn tapper by the
way did a good job in this interview
in that red zone we advocate for hybrid
elementary school
because we believe those k to five kids
are a transmitting less
and b really essential to have back in
the classroom
and if you're in middle school or high
school we would advocate for virtual
learning for that group or
if you're able to do six feet of strict
six feet of distancing
in those classrooms to open remotely in
a hybrid
way okay this is madness and it's
completely different with what she was
saying five minutes ago
five minutes ago malenski was saying
that the schools should be open and
teachers should be going back to school
really like oh we played it last week
she literally said that last week
and then the biden administration said
oh she was speaking in her personal
capacity
and then magically the cdc completely
shifted and they changed their guidance
to be completely anti-scientific
there is now significantly more evidence
that the biden administration
is cramming down its political teachers
unions standards
on the science than that trump ever did
this the rap on trump with regard to the
science that trump was ignoring
the science and forcing scientific
agencies to mirror him and this is the
wrap on on trump all the time
going all the way back to trump
redrawing the hurricane path with regard
to alabama you remember this with the
sharpie
okay well here's the thing when it comes
to actual hard scientific standards
there's way more evidence that the cdc
just
radically shifted its own standards in
order to meet the demands of joe biden
specifically and the teachers unions
that run him
than there is that trump ever did
anything like that and
fouch is doing the same thing by the way
right anthony fauci
is yeah i've grown increasingly critical
of voucher over the past year at the
beginning i was like you know i think
he's a guy trying to do his best then he
started appearing on the cover of in
touch magazine i was like okay this is a
guy who's really enjoying his celebrity
way too much he's given us conflicting
guidance on a variety of issues ranging
from masks to school reopenings now
anthony fauci who five minutes ago
was saying you know we should do reopen
the schools it's imperative actually
that we're up
we reopen the schools you know how much
cost it's having in terms of our kids
that we can't reopen the schools now you
have anthony fauci the greatest doctor
outside of joe biden in american history
saying that we actually should not
reopen the schools
the only way we should reopen the
schools according to anthony fauci is if
wait for it
wait for it joe biden's stimulus plan
passes
now we still have half a billion dollars
apparently in funding
for schools that has not been used yet
from the last
tranche of spending but that doesn't
matter does it sound like a scientific
standard to you or does it sound
like anthony fauci has his head up joe
biden's ass and joe biden has his head
up the teachers union's ass
i think that the schools really do need
more resources and that's
the reason why the national relief act
that we're talking about getting passed
we need that the schools need more
resources
the things we didn't have before there
wasn't that was there wasn't anything
that was put down
solidly on paper on saying these are the
kind of things that you should consider
these are the kind of things that you
should follow i mean there was talk
about it but it wasn't actually put down
in a single document that you could
access
the teachers the educators and everyone
else can
i think it can be done it's a pathetic
joke i'm sorry this is a pathetic joke
it has nothing to do with the science
it never had anything to do with the
science it always had to do with
political manipulation it's how andrew
cuomo became a hero while rhonda sanchez
in florida was the great villain
of this ridiculous morality play
desantis has been the best governor in
america on this stuff he runs the oldest
state in the country
it ranks in terms of deaths per million
somewhere in the 26
range okay and desantis has been crapped
on by the media while andrew cuomo who
is actively lying
to the american public and to seniors
and to members of his own party
about killing seniors by putting them
back in covet-infested nursing homes
i mean that guy was treated as a hero by
cnn and the rest of the media but this
guy's the villain ron desantis here is
desantis
pointing out quite clearly yesterday
that listen these lockdown policies have
not worked they do not work he is right
i lived in a lockdown state california
now has the most deaths of any state in
the union
and yet desantis is the bad guy somehow
here was desantis yesterday
if you look right now states that are
always held up by people in biden's
administration like new york
have way higher per capita patients
hospitalized for covid right now
so there's no basis in medical there's
no basis
in economics there's no basis in reality
to do this
except to punish a state that is doing
it better
than what his experts have recommended
biden is a lockdowner his advisors are
lockdowners
lockdowns don't work we've demonstrated
that
we're not turning back maria and they
will not be able to get away
with targeting florida yeah good good
for desantis who's been excellent on
this stuff and yet somehow he's the
villain of the piece by the way
there's no evidence emerging that what
i'm accusing the biden administration of
which is being run by the teachers
unions and twisting the science in order
to achieve their desired ends
that that is is well supported i'm going
to give you that evidence in just one
second first
let us talk about the fact that life is
just better when you are wearing a
comfortable pair of underwear
it's something you don't think about but
when you're wearing a really
uncomfortable pair of underwear it can
absolutely wreck
your day tommy john underwear it is the
best underwear on the market when you're
wearing tommy john you are that much
more comfortable you can do everything
better that's why tommy john doesn't
have customers they have fanatics
because with dozens of comfort
innovations once you've tried tommy john
you're never going back this is true i
throw i literally threw away all my
other underwear that were not tommy john
underwear
innovations like breathable lightweight
moisture-wicking fabric with four times
the stretch of competing brands with
over 13 million pairs sold
men across america love tommy john
underwear because they keep everything
in place no more flopping or sticking
and tommy john underwear comes with that
non-rolling waistband for the perfect
fit
the legs that never ride up and you are
covered with their no wedgie
guarantee which has come in super handy
for me many times
returns and exchanges are free right now
you get 15 off your first order at
tommyjohn.com
that is 15 off tommy john underwear and
loungewear at tommyjohn.com
ben that's tommyjohn.com ben see the
site for details tommyjohn.com
ben i love their stuff my wife loves
their stuff everybody loves their stuff
it's great fifteen percent off
tommyjohn.com
ben okay we're gonna get to more on the
cdc standards plus
joe biden continuing to try out more and
more radical policy i thought this was
the moderate administration
first got to remind you i'm sure you
know actress gina carano has been making
her way through the news cycle recently
she starred in the hit disney plus show
the mandalorian and then
she was canceled from the series and by
her talent agency
because she criticized the tyranny of
the woke hollywood mob
now at one point of time that would have
been the end of the story right that
just would have been another
conservative who was thrown out of the
culture
and then that the news cycle would have
moved on that is no
longer the case because we here at the
daily wire we reject cancel culture
and everything the authoritarian left
stands for and we are prepared to fight
back and we are putting our money where
our mouth is that is why we just
announced a movie deal with gina
so she will be developing producing and
starring in an upcoming film that will
be released exclusively
to daily wire members we've all said it
conservatives need to do more than
complain and critique and
whine about the culture we have to stop
running away from the culture we need to
be the creators and influencers
who challenge the leftist narrative in
hollywood we do that by creating
excellent art that stands on its own in
the world of entertainment and that's
why we are so excited to be announcing
our new partnership with gina the woke
mob they thought they were going to get
away with this they've got another thing
coming now here's the thing disney plus
they have eight
billion dollars to spend per year eight
billion with b
we've got you so join us today in the
fight to take back our culture head on
over to dailywire.com
subscribe use code gina that's g-i-n-a
to get 25
off your membership today this is the
way
you're listening to the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
[Music]
so here's the thing i actually have
evidence when i say that the biden
administration is run by the teachers
unions that we have the human centipede
of poop politics and at the very top of
that chain is the teachers union
followed by joe biden followed
by the cdc and then apparently followed
by the media so we are we are four deep
in this human centipede right now
listen to this report okay so a friday
press conference
cdc said this that the standards that
they are using quote
must be based on a thorough review of
what the science says u.s works and an
understanding of the lived
experiences challenges and perspectives
of teachers and school staff
parents and students apparently they
conducted in-depth reviews this is from
the cdc
transcript of their last press
conference we have conducted an in-depth
review
of the available science and evidence
base to guide our recommendations and
we've also engaged with many education
and public health partners
to hear firsthand from parents and
teachers directly about their
experiences
and concerns these sessions were so
informative and direct
changes to the guidance were made as a
result of them
the decision to go back to in-person
instruction is not one any of us take
lightly believe me
i know this is what willenski was saying
at cdc we have thoroughly reviewed the
science
and engaged with stakeholders as we
worked to produce an operational
strategy to support safe in-person
instruction and protect
teachers students and other school staff
that is uh that is spectacular stuff
right there
i mean truly spectacular that you now
have
the you now have rachelle wolenski
openly admitting
that they changed the scientific
standards based on input from the
stakeholders
now you may have heard of this term
stakeholders before because it's very
often used with regard to
stakeholder versus shareholder
capitalism quick review on that so when
it comes to corporations
the typical conservative viewpoint is
that corporations live
to serve their shareholders if you own a
share in the corporation it is the job
of the corporation to maximize the
potential value
of your share which makes sense you're
the one with skin in the game right you
bought a share of nike and now you want
that share of nike to go up so nike has
to make both short and long-term
decisions designed at maximizing the
stock price of your shares
then along come a bunch of people who
are on the social left and they say you
know what no
companies need to be thinking about the
stakeholders right people who are not
involved with the company
just people who are sort of outside the
system but may have an interest in
in what nike does so if you care about
shoes more generally or the environment
or people who are living in china
then you ought to impact nike's policy
the problem is that this turns corporate
boards into politicians okay the same
thing is true
when it comes to the cdc the cdc has one
mandate and one mandate only
and that is to give scientific guidance
i was told this over and over and over
during the trump era right
you were too follow tussayans right the
science is the only thing that matters
the science and if you don't follow the
science this makes you a bad person
now you have the cdc openly
acknowledging that they changed their
scientific guidance
based on the stakeholders people who
don't actually have skin in the
scientific
game they have other arenas of concern
they have other things they have to
worry about like
can we get our teachers more pay for
sitting at home and doing nothing that's
what the teachers unions are doing
but apparently we're now going to take
stakeholders into consideration
not the parents not the parents the
parents who want their kids back in
school the teachers unions
i mean this is extraordinary stuff so
now we have a biden administration that
is openly ignoring the science on
schools
in favor of to con and ignoring the
science on vaccines
in favor of two outside considerations
that have nothing to do with the science
one is what the teachers unions want to
do because when it comes to reopening
schools that's what they care about what
the teachers unions want to do
because one of the greatest scams in
american life is that
public sector unions exist in many
states and in the federal government
they bargain not against their employers
they bargain against the taxpayers
because in the end the taxpayers are the
employers but
they also elect the people they are
bargaining with because they spend
hundreds of millions of dollars every
election cycle to elect a bunch of
democrats they can then bargain with so
the democrats can give them taxpayer
money
and then they in turn can take a portion
of that and give it back to the
politicians to keep them elected it's
the most corrupt thing in american
politics it is openly corrupt there's
not even a shred
of cover for the corruption that exists
here and those are the people making the
scientific standards and then when it
comes to vaccine you have the biden
administration pushing equity equity
right because we have to determine what
special racial group
should receive additional privilege or
non-privilege in the american system
this is not an administration that gives
a damn about science this is an
administration that cares about outside
values
they're not following the science
they're following value systems and
value judgments that win them elections
that's all this is so don't give me that
this administration is motivated by
higher values
they are literally taking school
reopening standards
and they are twisting them inside the
cdc
the very thing they accuse donald trump
of doing but didn't really occur inside
the cdc
they are now openly doing in plain sight
and our media are like
it's good because joe biden's doing it
now because remember the threat to your
liberty
is is not the people who are openly
threatening your liberty by ignoring
hard data
and ignoring their own jobs in order to
gain power
it's the orange man bad who's not even
in office anymore keep your keep your
eye on that prize there gang
okay meanwhile you've got the biden
administration pushing for more and more
power
so over the weekend joe biden called for
gun control you knew this was coming
remember a good old joe
he said that he doesn't oppose guns good
old joe he's the kind of guy who owns a
i own a shotgun
if you ever have a pro by the way joe
biden's knowledge about shotguns
the if you could somehow crystallize
that knowledge into material form
joe biden's knowledge about guns could
fit inside a very small thimble
the man is an idiot when it comes to
this i mean when it comes to many things
but particularly this stuff
this is a guy who has suggested i'm not
kidding in past interviews
that if somebody is at your door and you
are afraid of them you should blast a
shotgun blast through the door
which is what oscar pistorius did and
then ended up
killing somebody in south africa like
that's illegal you can't do that
also he suggested that you never have to
fire an anger at somebody really you
just go up to your balcony and you fire
your gun in the air
i don't know if he's been watching too
many cowboy movies with dog-faced pony
soldiers or such but like
his knowledge about gun is just like he
doesn't know anything he's okay so
he has now come out and he has suggested
that he wants wide scale
gun bans essentially which should not be
a shock to any of you some of us were
saying this at the time
remember he invited up on the stage
he said that beta orc bra was going to
run gun policy the same beta o'rourke
who had suggested that he absolutely was
in favor of gun confiscations
joe biden said this upon his nomination
right
on super tuesday he said this he's so
joe biden has now called on congress to
pass what he calls quote common sense
gun law reforms
the statement comes from biden on the
three-year anniversary of the school
shooting massacre in parkland
quote three years ago today a lone
gunman took the lives of 14 students and
three educators
at marjory stoneman douglas high school
in parkland florida in seconds the lives
of dozens of families and life of the
american community were changed forever
for three years now the parkland
families have spent birthdays and
holidays without their loved ones
they've missed out on the experience of
sending their children off to college or
seeing them on their first job after
high school
like far too many families they've had
to bury pieces of their soul deep within
the earth like far too many families and
indeed like our nation they've been left
to wonder whether things would ever be
okay
these families are not alone in big
cities and small towns in schools and
shopping malls this is all joe biden's
statement in churches mosques synagogues
and temples in movie theaters and
concert halls on city street corners
that will never get a mention on the
evening news
all across our nation parents spouses
children siblings and friends have known
the pain of losing a loved one to gun
violence
and in the season of so much loss last
year's historic increase in homicides
across america
including the gun violence
disproportionately devastating black and
brown individuals in our cities
has added to the number of empty seats
at our kitchen tables i love that he
just slides that in
so there's been this massive increase in
homicide particularly in america's major
cities
did that have to do with lack of gun
control quick
quiz question what are the gun control
likes in gun control laws like
in um la chicago new york
washington d.c loose are they oh maybe
that increase in homicide was because
you and your political allies decided to
back a black lives matter movement
that actively suggested cutting funding
to the police and
instead replacing those police officers
with social workers
maybe that has something to do with
something maybe it's that you have spent
the last several years declaring along
with kamala harris that the police are
systemically racist
and this has led to police officers
being like you know what i'm not going
to go to that call because if i
am caught on tape doing the right thing
there's a good shot i end up getting
prosecuted so you know what
i'll just wait until the thing's over
and then i'll respond it's led to the
end of proactive policing
or maybe it's because you've seen
departments across the united states
withdraw funding by the way you know who
finally realized this minneapolis
minneapolis yesterday
came out with the announcement that they
had to add 6.4 million dollars
to the police budget oh you mean that
whole defunding the police thing didn't
work i can't believe it
i can't believe it so joe biden just
sticks right in the middle of this he
blames the increase
in murders across the united states and
in inner cities
not on the black lives matter
movements riotous offspring but instead
or on the on the black lives matter
movement's policy push to get rid of
cops
instead he puts it on gun control which
makes
less than zero sense it is anti-sense
okay so he continues
today as we mourn with the parkland
community we mourn for all who have lost
loved ones to gun violence
over these three years the parkland
families have taught us all something
profound time and again they've showed
us how we can turn our grief into
purpose to march organize and build a
strong inclusive durable movement for
change
et cetera et cetera he says this
administration will not wait for the
next mass shooting to heed that call
we will take action to end our epidemic
of gun violence and make our schools and
communities safer
so first of all all of the sort of
semantic game playing that happens with
regard to gun control is evidence in
this statement
whenever he says things like gun
violence understand guns don't violent
themselves
guns are tools like the pen i'm holding
this pen cannot write by itself
otherwise it would be magic guns do not
fire themselves
if you wish to disincentivize people
shooting one another perhaps we should
have more cops on our streets but again
this goes very much against what joe
biden is in favor of
also unanswered remains the question as
to why there are certain areas of the
united states with extraordinary levels
of gun ownership
and yet very very low gun murder rates
in places like for example vermont which
has very very lacks
gun laws they never answer these
particular questions because the
questions are awkward
right why is it that switzerland has
very high levels of gun ownership and
very little gun violence
perhaps people's pulling the trigger is
really the problem not inanimate objects
sitting there on the table
so there's that euphemism that's always
used gun violence as opposed to you know
the problem of murder
because if you if you broaden it out and
you say the problem of murder then
instead of focusing on the instrument of
the murder you might focus on the people
responsible for the murder and try and
capture them and put them in jail
but that's not what joe biden wants to
do he's very much in favor of fewer
people in jail including people who are
dangerous
okay also when he says the epidemic of
gun violence
okay an epidemic is something that
spreads from person to person i have
never been infected with this epidemic
because it's not an epidemic it's people
committing an act of evil
evil is not an epidemic it's not
catchable you have to decide to engage
in an act of evil like shooting a gun at
another human being
anyway joe biden then gets to his policy
preferences he says today i'm calling on
congress to enact common sense gun law
reforms by the way common sense in
democrats because i don't have any
evidence to back this
but i think it might be a good idea so
let's do it democrats have yet
to provide a proposal that would have
stopped what happened at parkland
they've yet to provide a proposal that
would have stopped what happened at
sandy hook
they've yet to provide a proposal that
would have stopped what happened in the
san bernardino shooting
all of their proposals are actively
geared toward not doing those things and
they admit as much
barack obama used to admit this he used
to say this right people would ask him
so
you want to pass a gun law after sandy
hook that wouldn't have stopped sandy
hook
and you'd be like it's true it might not
have stopped sandy hook but it might
stop another shoot okay well
yeah but that's not what we're talking
about are we like how about a gun law
that's calibrated to the particular
policy you're talking about
one of the reasons by the way that
democrats keep focusing in on mass
shootings as opposed to the everyday
problem of people killing each other
with guns
is because usually when people kill each
other with guns it is done with handguns
mass shootings are disproportionately
done with long guns democrats
want to go after long guns because long
guns look scary and also
because long guns are easier to regulate
and they're easier to track there are
too many handguns in circulation and
they know this
so instead they just ignore handguns and
so the reality is what democrats would
love more than anything else is a vast
gun confiscation that's what they would
want hillary clinton has praised the
australian gun buyback plan which was a
mandatory gun buyback
by the way still ended with only one
third of the guns in australia actually
being turned in
so joe biden says i'm calling on
congress to enact common-sense gun law
reforms including
requiring background checks on all gun
sales which means that if i
sell a gun to my brother-in-law then
this means that they want a background
check
so in order for that to happen you would
need a national gun registry that is the
only way for that to happen is for the
government to know every single gun in
america and where it is and how it is
and how it is transmitted hands
banning assault weapons he doesn't
define assault weapons but assault
weapons presumably include all the
scary-looking ones
and high-capacity magazines and
eliminating immunity for gun
manufacturers okay now this is the big
one
so democrats have been pushing for a
long time this idea that gun
manufacturers
should be on the hook liably they should
be they should have liability
they should be liable for a bad person
misusing
their their gun this does not exist in
any other category of products liability
it doesn't right if i were to take a
chainsaw which is normally used for
cutting down trees and i were to go over
to my neighbor's house
in order to chainsaw my neighbor you
know who would not be liable is the
chainsaw manufacturer
because among the non-recommended uses
chainsawing my neighbor
if i heard it would chip or somebody
like fargo
the person's family could not then sue
the wood chipper
and say you know what not really your
fault but you sold the wood chipper to
that guy and that guy was bad news
hey the purpose of a gun is not to shoot
an innocent person the purpose of a gun
is to defend yourself
or to defend liberty in the final
instance
but if that gun is misused the notion
that the gun manufacturer should be
somehow liable for that is a way of
putting gun manufacturers out of
business that's what it is that's what
it is designed to do
it is not that gun manufacturers have
some sort of exemption in law
is that gun manufacturers ought not be
liable for the misuse of their products
to do bad things
it is a very silly suggestion that that
be done except it's not silly it's an
attempt to destroy gun manufacturers
that is what he wants he wants legal
liability extended to people who misuse
your product
it doesn't exist in any other area of
american law
so that is what joe biden is pushing for
yeah this is this moderate show good old
moderate show who loves guns we've been
told meanwhile
joe biden is about to allow ten tens of
thousands of illegal immigrants
into texas and california communities
according to john binder reporting for
breitbart
president joe biden's department of
homeland security is planning to release
about 25
600 migrants who have been in mexico
into american communities in texas and
california
according to breitbart news after biden
ended the remain in mexico policy which
drastically reduced asylum fraud by
keeping migrants in mexico while they
await asylum hearings in the united
states
dhs announced it would begin processing
the 25 600 migrants in the program on
february 19th
ultimately all of those migrants will
enter the united states interior
internal communications from that
breitbart news has reviewed show
dhs plans to release the migrants in san
diego el paso and brownsville texas
those were locations the biden
administration refused to divulge
to the ap when asked in san diego dhs
plans to process and release about 300
migrants a day within
two weeks of february 19. by the way the
remain in mexico policy
makes a lot of sense but the the biden
administration is attempting to end it
because they don't actually oppose
illegal immigration
in any serious way meanwhile in other
radical biden administration policy
so i had been informed by
administrations of both parties
that the american alliance with israel
was unshakable remember
they kept saying over we're not an
anti-israel administration no they kept
saying this
in obama's administration sure they were
allowing
radically anti-semitic u.n resolutions
to go forward in the last days of the
biden administration
of the obama administration sure they
pushed forward an iran nuclear deal that
put at existential risk israel
but they weren't anti-israel well now
the mask is kind of slipping here so gen
zaki the garbage white house press
secretary
she was asked specifically if saudi
arabia and israel were allies of the
united states
now normally the answer to that question
is yes they are
because they have historically been
allies to the united states doesn't mean
you can't hold your allies accountable
we have lots of allies we disagree with
but to pretend that israel is not an
ally of the united states is crazy and
we are now
yeah i mean joe biden was put into
office on february 20th
we we've now on january 20th we have now
had nearly a month and joe biden still
has not put in a call to prime minister
benjamin netanyahu of israel
a month he's talked to world leaders all
over the place he's talked to enemy
world leaders he's talked to friendly
world leaders he still has not called
benjamin netanyahu
why because joe biden doesn't like
netanyahu and because the democrats in
power do not like israel
they made this rather clear yesterday
gensake refused to acknowledge israel as
an ally and said she'd have to circle
back on that
does the administration still consider
the saudis and the israelis important
allies
uh well you know again i think we
there are ongoing processes and internal
interagency processes one that we i
think confirmed an interagency meeting
just last week to discuss
a range of issues in the middle east um
where we've only been here three and a
half weeks
and i think i'm going to let those
policy processes see themselves through
before we give kind of a
complete lay down of what our national
security approaches will be to a range
of issues okay so she doesn't know where
they are on that one that seems like a
pretty easy answer but they can't give
it because this administration is
radical
it was always going to be radical some
of us warned that it was a trojan horse
for radicalism americans decided to vote
for that anyway well now
americans are going to get the benefit
of the bargain we are going to get it
good and hard
alrighty we're going to be here later
today with an additional hour of content
in the meantime go check out the michael
knowles show he's discussing meghan
mccain's take on
the lincoln project you can hear more
details about that story over on
michael's show it's available right now
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling production
manager pavel wydowsky
our associate producers are rebecca
doyle and savannah dominguez the show is
edited by adam scievents
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant jessica crand the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright 2021
the senate votes not to convict donald
trump making him the most acquitted
president in american history my
doppelganger resigns
from the white house and president bibi
remakes u.s policy check it out on the
michael knowles show